ce n'est pas la première offensive de
l'Ukraine en Crimée
mais c'est peut-être l'une des plus
audacieuses depuis des mois vendredi
dernier un missile s'est abattu sur le
quartier général de la flotte russe à
Sébastopol en Crimée annexé un missile
qui aurait tué le commandant de la
flotte russe de la mer Noire Victor
Sokoloff ce sont les Forces Spéciales
ukrainiennes qu'il annonce sur
télégramme sans pour autant en apporter
la preuve 34 officiers dont le
commandant de la flotte russe de la mer
Noire sont morts sont cinq autres
occupants ont été blessés le bâtiment du
quartier général est tiré parable de son
côté Moscou qui ne communique presque
jamais sur ses pertes dans la guerre en
Ukraine ne fait état que d'un militaire
disparu après l'attaque mais le symbole
est très fort illustre les difficultés
de la défense anti-aérienne russe à
contrer les frappes ukrainiennes sur
cette péninsule
occupé depuis 2014 un territoire
stratégique pour Moscou dans la
logistique des troupes russes mais que
KFC juré depuis le début de la guerre de
reprendre dans son intégralité